I don't know.
You've probably come across this little
diagram in the book and it's quite a
complicated diagram,
so I'm going to just walk you through it
a bit and then he'll tell you the
Egyptian story.
So this is,
this is a sequence of interconnected
causal loop.
So the question might be,
well,
how does morality emerged from the
bottom?
And I would say,
well,
especially the morality that's
associated with assuming that attention
is something that's sacred,
roughly speaking.
Okay,
so managing,
you'll see someone reading engaged in
something,
you might think,
oh,
I'd really like to be engaged like that,
which is what you would think,
right?
Because everyone wants that.
It's like,
I'd like to be engaged.
Okay,
so then you might think,
well,
this person looks like they're fully
alive.
Something like that.
They're not being obsessed by
catastrophes and all that.
They're into what they're doing.
What's that like?
Okay.
You'd say,
well,
that's associated with creative
exploration.
And then you might say,
well,
why is creative exploration useful in
the answer to that is because it can
generate adaptive behavior of all sorts.
Okay,
so then what?
Well then you can imitate the adaptive
behavior because we can use our bodies
as representational devices.
So we act out the person who's
interested in something.
So that's actually in large part why
people like to buy art,
you know?
So lots of people I've seen by arc,
they liked to buy art because they also
have some contact with the artists and
they want to have some contact methey
artists because it's kind of cool to
have contact with an artist.
It brings something into their life.
And the artist is definitely someone
who's outside standard hierarchies.
That's sort of what defines an artist.
So then once you imitate the adaptive
behavior,
then you can play around with the
invitations a bit and you can ritualize
them and then you can dramatize them and
dramas and interesting thing.
Once it gets,
once it gets formalized,
you know,
because basically what you're doing,
imagine little kids,
they get together,
they lay out some rules for pretend
play.
Then they run us pretend play
simulation.
Then imagine like little shakespeare
junior is off to the side and he's taken
some notes and maybe he watches six or
seven different pretend play episodes
and he thinks,
well,
this was the most interesting part of
that and this was the most interesting
part of that.
This was the most interesting part of
that.
I think I'll put those all together,
make them coherent.
We'll have a really good story.
And what the story is is an articulated
representation of a dramatic
representation of a set of procedures.
It's two orders of abstraction,
right?
And you know this because when you read
a book,
I mean this doesn't happen to me anymore
because I think I've read too many
books,
but I can remember when I was a kid,
when I was reading a book of fiction,
it was as if the,
what was being described was playing out
in my imagination as embodied fingers.
So you know,
sometimes you go to a movie of a book,
you've read and you think,
oh,
that person doesn't look anything like
the person in the book,
you know,
because you have a representation of
what the person is like.
I found as I've gotten older that,
and I don't understand this is I don't
have that anymore,
but I still understand the books so I
must've become so automatized.
But that's all gone.
It's,
it's,
it's a loss I would say.
But anyways,
it doesn't matter.
You see that once you get the bloody
dram or written down or even when you
can say it,
when you can tell a story,
you're so close to having the,
the pattern revealed in an articulated
manner.
You can't say what the pattern is,
but you can describe it well once you
can describe it,
well,
you're right next to philosophy,
right?
As soon as we have a set of dramas that
we can all agree on,
especially once they get written down,
then we can start thinking about the
dramas.
And that's when philosophy enters the
stage.
As far as I can tell,
it's like the groundwork for look for
philosophy has already laid by centuries
and centuries of human interaction.
And we keep out abstracting that up to
the point where we can represent it and
then we can pull out general principles
and we discussed them and debate about
them.
But that's the birth of philosophy and
all of those levels interplay.
Like it's not just the causal direction
isn't just from creative exploration
forward.
It's each time you add a new level that
interacts with the previous level,
right?
So you can talk about how you're going
to play or you can analyze literature,
you know,
or you can think about what you're going
to write about.
So,
so each time you add another level of
the capacity for abstraction,
you make the whole system much more
dynamic and complex.
So the causal links,
that's why there's all those little
arrows on outside.
All of those areas are interacting with
each other.
So yes,
Rama.
Yeah.
Too many arrows.
Let me show you something here.
This is quite cool.
See that?
Did I show you that before?
Oh,
this is so cool.
It's mind boggling,
this thing.
Okay.
So the horizontal line,
you see all the little squiggles that
are underneath that.
Okay.
Every one of those lines is a biblical
verse.
And the length of the line corresponds
to how many references there is to that
verse in other places in the book.
So you look at the bloody thing,
man,
that thing's hyperlinked,
like mad.
And that's partly why the book,
you know,
think about this book like a normal
book.
Really what you do.
No,
you go see a movie and there's a
timeline.
There's a beginning and a middle and an
end,
but it's a losery,
right?
Because the person who was writing the
movie saw the whole thing at once.
And so they could use their knowledge of
the ending to fiddle around with the
beginning and they could use their
knowledge of the middle to fiddle around
with the end.
That doesn't happen in real life.
So you can lay this out.
Now imagine you've got a story and it's
like 5,000
years old and a 150,000
people have edited it and they all knew
the end and the middle and the beginning
and they just go like this.
Well,
this means this and that refers to this.
And that refers to this and that refers
to this and this means that.
And well you end up with that.
It's like it's infinitely dance.
You can't get to the bottom of it.
There's no way.
And really it's hyperlinked.
So you,
I could,
you could say that in a sense.
The Bible is the world's first fully
hyperlink document.
Weird.
So,
Yup.
Yes.
And,
and part of that's part of,
that's actually conscious.
Like one of the things that people do
when they're criticizing Christianity is
say,
well if you look at the gospel stories
for example,
there'll be a little story about Christ
and then there'll be this line that says
thus fulfilling Isaiah's prophecy and
the biblical scholars say,
look,
that was put in later.
And the reason it was put in later was
because the,
the hypothesis of the savior is nested
in the Old Testament and it keeps
partially coming true with all these
profits.
So a profit is like a partial savior.
And in the Old Testament prophets are
just popping up like mad.
And usually what happens is Israel gets
degenerate for one reason or another.
It's because the king isn't being a good
martech basically.
And so then a prophet who's very
insightful,
like Nietzsche or Dostoevsky pops up and
says,
hey,
you're not paying attention to the
orphans and widows and you better get
your act together because otherwise
God's going to come along and like
flood.
Yeah,
out or your enemies are going to stream
in.
And of course,
often weirdly enough,
the king's listen because they think,
God,
this person is either completely insane
or God's talking to him because
otherwise he wouldn't be marching into
the court when I could have his head cut
off with one 10th of a second orders.
So often they kind of half pay
attention.
But what happens,
and this is northrop fries
interpretation fundamentally,
is that the whole testament is the
construction of an empire.
Israel,
it's collapsed because of its failure to
follow the fundamental moral order.
Then it rises again,
collapses,
rises again,
collapses.
The first story like that is the flood,
right?
And that's a really,
really old story.
You know,
the Bible doesn't get quasi historic
until Abraham,
the stories before that.
So that would be like the creation of
the world,
Adam and eve.
Um,
the Tower of Babel,
Cain and Abel.
No,
no.
That's later Noah.
And then,
then the Abrahamic story start.
And that's more like the history of
Israel.
Even though it's also mythologized the
first set of stories,
man,
those things are old.
Who knows how old,
really old,
50,000
years old.
Maybe they're old.
So anyways,
what happens across time is that people
have all these biblical books and it's
like what the Mesopotamians had to do in
order to organize their society.
It's like,
oh,
we've got all these writings,
they're all sacred.
Hypothetically,
they contradict each other.
They don't seem to be in any order.
Like what are we going to do about that?
And so then there's this collaboration
of minds across to think,
oh hell,
he kind of looks like this might go
there and then this might go there.
And this refers to that.
And so it is that it's tar,
it's trying to,
it's the collective imagination of
humanity trying to make a coherent story
out of experience.
That's what it is.
And you know,
it's,
you might say,
well it's our best guess.
Is it true?
It depends on what you mean by true,
right.
That's a very,
very tricky question.
Partly this,
the question it's trying to answer is
how should you act?
Let's not the story that's not a
scientific story,
but it's a bloody important question.
Okay,
good.
So Egypt,
I felt like you didn't know the story
of,
what was his name?
Yeah,
who discovered buoyancy?
He ran through the streets.
Eureka.
Who was that?
Archimedes.
Okay.
So archimedes was trying to figure out
how to measure the volume of something.
And He,
I think he wanted to figure out how you
determined whether an alloy was pure
gold or not.
And so you'd have to get the volume of
the damn thing and then maybe at a clump
of metal,
there's no way you could measure.
And then he figured out that if you had
a tub full of water and you drop the
thing in it,
the amount of water that spilled over
the edges would tell you exactly how big
the thing was.
And then you could weigh your thing,
your metal,
and you could tell what proportion of it
was gold.
And so he was so thrilled about that.
He theoretically,
he discovered that when he was in a
bathtub,
he got it in,
the water spilled over.
He ran naked through the streets of
whatever townie was in yelling.
Eureka.
I've got it.
So,
so that's an insight,
right?
So I felt like that when I,
when I read this Egyptian story and I
thought I figured it out.
So because I thought,
wow,
that's mind boggling.
So here's the story.
So we got to show you some of these
characters.
Hmm.
So the guy in the middle,
that's,
so cyrus,
he's on this pillar.
So he started,
represents what pillars represent,
which is what whole things up.
Okay.
And then the guy on the left,
that's horace and horace is,
he's got the head of a forking.
Okay.
And the reason for that is that falcons
fly around so they're not attached to
the ground.
And they can really,
really,
really see,
like they're birds of prey in there,
about the only animal who can see better
than us.
So like rap doors,
birds of prey,
they can see like mad.
Think an eagle.
If an eagle was standing on the top of
the empire state building,
it could see a dime on the sidewalk.
So it's like Gold Eagle.
And then the one on the right is isis
and Isis is queen of the underworld.
Okay.
And then there's one other character
here.
You see that's a Madonna and child.
Basically.
There are that character.
That's seth and seth is,
he's a bad guy now.
No one knows what the hell seth is.
You know,
nobody's been able figure out what kind
of weird animal that is.
So who knows?
But those are the four main characters.
Okay.
So now you got to know how they interact
here.
So you'd go to Cyrus and the store.
There's variants of this story,
many,
but I'm telling you like one sort of
canonical variant.
So story of Osiris and Isis and horace.
Yeah.
So,
um,
and this is the story upon which
Egyptian civilization was based,
although it was a very old civilization,
right?
Lasted for thousands of years.
So Cleopatra was last time from
Cleopatra to now than there is between
Cleopatra and the Pyramids.
So that kind of tells you how old Egypt
was.
It's like old major civilization lasted
a long time,
had a powerful story,
a powerfully organizing story,
right.
Way older than like,
then the history of Judeo Christian
civilization,
say 2000 years old,
older than Chinese history.
It's old.
China goes back a long ways though.
So,
you know,
maybe it's not older than China,
but it's something there.
Anyways,
well cyrus,
so,
oh cyrus was that God who established
Egypt?
Okay,
so he's like George Washington.
If you had George Washington 2000 years
from now,
then George Washington would be able to
cyrus because he'd be mythologized,
right?
So basically,
oh,
cyrus represents all the good things
that the Egyptians did to establish
order from chaos and set up the society.
So Cyrus,
he's a great,
he was a great hero when he was young
and he did all sorts of heroic things.
And he established the state of Egypt
and he rules over it,
but he's kind of old and he can't see as
well as he used to.
And he's little on the muddle headed
side,
but worse than that.
So He's archaic and anachronistic.
And so what that indicates is that,
well,
just like the Americans are experiencing
with their constitution,
it's like,
hmm,
things a little on the old side.
What should we do with it while we
should update?
It's like,
well we don't want to update it in a way
that makes all chaos break forth,
you know?
So anyways,
things get our cat just because they
exist,
right?
So if you set up a system of rules,
it's tea,
it's supposed to adapt to this
environment,
but the environment keeps wiggling
around,
right?
So you have to chase it with the rules
and you have to update the rules as the
landscape changes.
And that's the biologists call that the
red queen problem,
roughly speaking,
which is a reference to Alice in
wonderland.
So Alice goes down the rabbit hole and
she finds the Red Queen.
That's the queen of chaos,
Mother Nature.
And what,
and she's always chopping people's heads
off for arbitrary reasons,
like,
yeah.
Um,
and one of the things she tells Ellis'
here in my kingdom,
you have to run as fast as you can just
to stay in the same place.
And that's the chronic human problem.
It's the problem of entropy,
right?
Is that you build something static but
things aren't static.
So even if it's a useful thing you've
built,
first of all,
you got to maintain the hell out of it
cause it's just going to fall apart.
But worse than that,
the environments running away from it.
And so your computers have oh,
cyrus problems all the time.
It's like they're just lovely for the
first three years that you own them and
then their bricks.
And it's because the underlying
landscape is so dynamic that the
structure you loses its validity.
You can almost watch it lose its
validity,
right?
As a consequence of the exponential
increase in computer intelligence.
So Cyrus great guy,
when he was young,
little old fashioned and worse,
he's willfully blind.
Now the Egyptians insisted on that and
that's so cool.
It's actually you can be held
responsible in an English common law
court for willful blindness.
And what willful blindness is.
The failure is the failure to realize
something you could have realized.
So for example,
if you're a CEO and you have a crooked
chief financial officer and you think
maybe he's crooked,
but you decide,
well,
I'm not going to look at the books
because then I know,
and then his malfeasance is brought to
light and you say,
well,
I didn't know the prosecutor will say,
yeah,
but you could have.
And you knew you could have and you
didn't.
And so you're,
you're culpable for your own ignorance.
It's like that's such a brilliant idea.
The Egyptians figured this out.
Oh,
cyrus is not only old and decrepit and a
little on the Alzheimer he side,
but he won't pay attention to things.
He's had it with that.
He's willfully blind.
And that's a problem because he has a
brother who's the evil brother of the
rightful king,
which is a theme that you're all
familiar with.
If you watched your Disney movies,
he's like scar in the lion king,
right?
Same Guy.
Or in a Latin,
there's,
uh,
some bad character.
I don't remember his name.
Alert.
That's the guy.
Yeah.
And so,
you know,
he's the,
he's the evil or,
or Darth vader in star wars.
It's like,
it's,
he's an archetypal figure.
He's the evil brother of the rightful
king.
Now,
why does the rightful king has an evil
brother?
That's easy.
It's because organizations tend towards
decay and corruption across time.
That's what they do.
And the Socialists are really on this
with regards to corporations,
right?
The evil corporations,
it's like,
and the,
and the right wingers,
thank,
oh no,
it's evil government.
So they're just projecting the archetype
of the negative farther onto the respect
of organizations,
when in fact,
it's actually a characteristic of
organizations.
If you don't keep an eye on the damn
things,
they degenerate and they become corrupt.
So that's just what happens.
You better stay awake to deal with that.
So anyways,
oh,
cyrus has this evil brother named seth
and seth,
the name Seth Becomes Satan through the
Coptic Christians much,
much,
much later.
So he's like the precursor to the,
to the devil,
roughly speaking.
Now.
Oh Cyrus think staff is all right,
like,
like scar does or like move Fossa does
with scarp underestimates his danger.
Something you should never do.
And so one day,
oh cyrus,
he's just not paying much attention and
seth gets a big symitar something like
that,
chops them into pieces.
And then,
because you can't really kill oh cyrus,
because he's a god as well as being the
founder of the state and the ruler,
the only thing you can do is make it
difficult for him to get his act back
together.
So what seth does is he takes so Cyrus's
pieces and he scatters them all over
Egypt.
And the idea there is that when
corruption overtakes and organization,
then things fall apart.
But the things aren't actually dead.
You know,
it's like when a corporation falls
apart,
all the people in it don't die.
They just fragment into maybe smaller
groups.
Some companies get spun off or maybe
they fragment all the way down to the
individual level,
but there's still potency left in it.
And the structure is still there inside
each of the individuals and the sub
organizations.
So you can,
you can get the damn thing to fall
apart,
but you can't get rid of it so far.
And he does that.
He scatters these pieces everywhere.
So it makes it hard for old cyrus to
recollect himself or to get his act back
together.
So things fall apart and it's hard for
you to get your act back together.
That's the idea.
And so,
and then he rules the kingdom,
which doesn't work out very well.
Just like scar in the lion king,
right?
Because he's an evil tyrant and all
things considered evil.
Tyranny doesn't work that well even for
the evil tyrant.
Well though you should never assume that
an evil tyrant wants things to work out.
Well,
not even for him.
So anyways,
fine.
Oh,
Cyrus has a wife,
isis now isis,
she's a major league player in ancient
mythology.
Isis as queen of the underworld.
And it's a real costs up.
If you look at archaic cultures,
whether the top God is the guy with the
order guy like,
oh cyrus or the top God is Isis.
He's queen of the underworld.
It's like it's 50 50 for sure.
And well,
isis represents chaos and oh,
Cyrus represents order and they should
be in balance.
Like,
you know,
if they're in a harmonious balance like
Appsu and Tiamat and they produce all
sorts of productive things and if one
overwhelms the other,
well then it's not so good.
So they should be a harmonious couple.
Okay.
But now I was,
cyrus is dead whack.
He's chopped up and spread everywhere.
So op isis comes out of the underworld.
Well that's what happened when the
Americans invaded Iraq.
It's like,
wow,
well cyrus has gone.
Yeah,
but what about Isis?
Oh,
we forgot about isis up she comes chaos.
It's like,
there it is.
So is it better?
No,
I don't obviously.
So you never want to forget about isis.
So anyways,
Isis,
not that happy that,
oh sorry,
Russ has gone because that's her
husband,
right?
And she thinks,
well that's not so,
so helpful.
So what she does is she runs around
Egypt trying to find his fellas.
And the reason for that is because it,
it's the seminal apparatus,
right?
It's the seed of the new thing.
So what she does is she finds his
Phallus and she makes herself pregnant
with it.
And so bang,
she goes back down to the underworld.
But now she's impregnated.
So what does that mean?
It means when remarkable things fall
apart into chaos,
the seeds of something new or
potentially planted.
Okay.
So fine.
She gives birth to horace,
like Arthur,
he's outside his rightful kingdom,
just like Simba standard routine,
just like Harry Potter,
right?
He's outside his kingdom.
And the reason for that is you're all
outside your kingdom.
It's like the Kingdom is Sorta old and
archaic and doesn't quite fit the
circumstances now.
And it's not all that fair to you and
it's sort of arbitrary.
And so you grow up to some degree and
[inaudible] opposition to it.
So it's just an archetypal story.
So this,
this character,
she finally gives birth to this
character and that.
So Cyrus and no cyrus,
he's,
he's quite the character.
He's that.
So sorry.
That's all.
Sorry.
His name is horace and that's horace
there.
And she's the benevolent goddess of all
new things as well as being the terrible
goddess of the underworld.
And she knows she's bringing up horace.
Horace,
where is he here?
There he is.
So Horace is,
this is fulcan cause he can fly around
and see everything and he's also the eye
of the Egyptians.
And so it's like,
he's like Marduk these eyes he can see,
okay,
so then horace grows up and he's
thinking,
Huh,
not fond the world stuff.
I'd like to have my kingdom back,
my rightful kingdom.
And now he's different than oh cyrus.
And the reason these different is
because he can see and normally can he
see,
he will see.
And that's a whole different thing.
So Horace is not willfully blind and
that's a drag because he can see what's
happened to the kingdom and he can see
south and that's not so good.
It's like you're in in Romeo declares
position then aren't you?
You have to shake hands with the devil.
And you know what happened to Romeo,
dell error when that happened.
It's like post term.
He's a general right.
I hope you know all know this,
you know he was there in Rwanda when
everybody got massacred in the u.
N didn't step in property.
Had to watch all that.
It was like post traumatic stress
disorder instantly.
So it's like if your eyes open and you
can see evil,
it's like you better look out because if
you're face to face with real
malevolence the probability that that
will damage your brain is very high.
You know?
And one of the things that's very
interesting if you think about post
traumatic stress disorder is that often
in soldiers it's,
it's,
it's a consequence of something they
did,
not something they saw.
So they'll go out in the battlefield and
they'll find out there far more barbaras
and cruel and destructive than they ever
possibly imagined.
And then they,
how are they going to fit that into like
corn fed farm boy from Iowa skied,
you know,
they can't do it.
Poof,
the whole structure is gone.
It's very stressful to find that sort of
thing out.
And the people I've had in my practice
who have had ptsd,
it's almost always because they were
subjected to some kind of malevolence
like it was,
they came face to face with something
evil.
And in one case,
for example,
I had a client whose boyfriend was going
to rape her.
She was naive beyond belief and what
[inaudible] gave her a posttraumatic
stress disorder wasn't what he did
because she could fight him off.
She happened to be bigger than he was.
It was the look of malevolence on his
face when he attacked her.
That was enough and it she had severe
psychosomatic syndrome symptoms for four
years.
After that,
she couldn't even sleep.
Her whole body would vibrate and it took
a lot of untangling before we figured
out that it was the look on his face and
I've seen that happen.
Other times it's like becoming face to
face with this sort of thing is no joke.
So horace can see,
but luckily he's a long ways from it.
Yeah.
Yes,
I can imagine.
He ended up becoming making,
right.
That's a nat tay.
That's to put the chaos back in an Ed.
One thing you might want to know about
Hitler is that one day in World War One,
he got a medal for bravery in world war
one by the way.
So Hitler was all sitting around with
his buddies in a trench and he went off
to relieve himself.
And when he came back they were all dead
because the shell had landed right in
the middle.
And so that gave him the idea that he
was saved for something special.
And I can tell you if that happened to
you,
you would feel,
cause what are you using your options.
It's a horrible,
chaotic,
nasty place where brutal things happen
at random.
That's one option.
Or You were saved because something
special is waiting for you.
So like it's toss up which of those two
you're going to pick,
but you're going to pick one of them.
So anyways,
okay,
so horace,
he can see sec too bad for him.
So he goes back to the kingdom and he
has like vicious fight with scent and
sets like they're pretty evenly matched.
And so the idea there is that even if
your horse,
like son of the,
of order and son of chaos and your eyes
are open,
it's like it's a pretty evil,
it's a pretty even battle.
So they're fighting away and seth gets
to apprehend and he tears out one of
horses eyes.
And then horace,
which is pretty damaging,
you know,
that's a drag to lose an eye.
So his vision is damaged by his with
evil.
But Horace keeps fighting and eventually
he prevails and it gets the eye back and
he banishes seth to the Nether regions
of the kingdom.
It's like in the lion king where you
know everything,
the light touches is the kingdom and
then there's the nether regions is
that's where your sandal seth.
So you can't get rid of him,
can't kill him.
He's permanent because societies will
always tend towards corruption.
Best you can do is get the damn guy
under control for a while.
Okay,
so now horace has his eye and you think
and of story,
pretty good story.
You could animate that.
He just slapped the old I back in his
hand,
you know,
pick up the sector and he'd rule happily
ever after.
Now it isn't what happens.
What happens instead is he take,
he keeps his eye and he goes back to the
underworld and he finds those Cyrus's
ghosts down there and it's sort of
sitting there like this,
you know,
it's cause it's all chopped up and you
know,
it's a weird combination because in one
plane it's,
it's a chopped up body that's
distributed everywhere.
But down in the underworld,
it's like a ghost,
the spirit,
but it's not very animated.
It's sort of in the land of the dead,
like Pinocchio's farther in the whale.
So what does this whole horse do?
Well,
he gives,
oh cyrus his eye.
So now blind tradition can see and then
he takes his father,
oh cyrus backup to the surface sort of.
Now they're a unit arm in arm,
so to speak.
And it's the,
it's the combination of horizontal Cyrus
that rule Egypt.
And that's what the Egyptians figured
out.
It's like,
God,
that's so smart.
It's like,
well you need this,
you need the traditions of the state,
right,
because you need them.
They're there,
they're vital,
they hold back chaos.
You can't just let that go because then
income seth and up comes the underworld.
It's like that's not good.
You need that as a bulwark.
But then it's old and kind of blind and
it's going to tend towards corruption
and fall over of its own accord.
So how do you solve that?
And the answer is it pay attention and
you provide dead tradition with living
site.
And if you do that,
then you get to be the ruler of the
state,
the rightful ruler of the state.
Now the Egyptians basically hypothesize,
this took a long time,
that the Pharaoh also had an immortal
soul.
He was the only person who did.
But the immortal soul was basically the
combination of Horace and oh Cyrus.
So the Egyptians conceptualize that as
something that was eternal.
So,
and it was the,
it was the eternal,
it was the central eternal feature of
sovereignty.
It's so smart.
And so as long as the Pharaoh was a good
horace Ando Cyrus at the same time,
then he was the rightful sovereign and
he was reflecting something of the
utmost value.
And it was a mortal.
It's so smart.
So what happens,
interestingly,
they call this the democratization of
old cyrus.
So to begin with in the Egyptian state,
you could only use the horace.
Oh Cyrus symbolism.
If you were either of the Pharaoh to
begin with,
or at least a high ranking aristocrat.
But what happened as Egypt progressed,
so to speak,
as it developed across time,
is that the right to use the symbolism
that that was the horror.
So Cyrus conjunction drifted down the
dominance hierarchy.
So at some point all the aristocrats got
to use,
it never drifted down to like women are
Carmen,
people are slaves or anything like that.
But you know,
hypothetically the Jews came out of
Egypt and one of the things the Jews
said that went beyond the Egyptians was
that each person was,
was capable,
was ennobled in some sense by their
potential relationship with the highest
value that was gone.
And when the Christian showed up.
But that was universalized everyone had
it,
even prostitutes and slaves.
So it's so cool because what happens is
these societies get the idea of,
of sovereignty laid out in this
phenomenal heavenly drama.
And they identify that with the thing
that's at the top of the hierarchy,
which is what they should do.
But then what happens across time is
everybody wakes up and thinks,
oh,
that's so interesting.
It's characteristic of the Pharaoh.
It's characteristic of what should be
sovereign.
It's characteristic of what the highest
value is,
but it's actually characteristic of
everybody and it's,
it's almost impossible to overstate how
important that is because our whole
conception of the idea of natural rights
is predicated on the idea that there's
something about you as an individual
individual whose value is inviolable so
much that it doesn't even matter what
you do.
So if I see you brutally murdered 20
people and there's 50 eye witnesses and
we know for sure you did it,
you still have to be treated as if your
central essence is of tremendous value
and you have to be given due process.
The whole law bows down before that.
And so then you think,
well,
do people believe this?
This sort of horace oh cyrus combination
and its relationship to what's
ultimately valuable and the fact that
that's embodied in every person.
It's like they certainly act like they
believe it.
And if,
if they ever encounter a violation of
that in practice,
especially social practice,
everybody's jumping up and down in
complaining.
It's like you're trampling on my rights.
What do you mean?
Where'd those come from?
What exactly?
What are they and are they real or not?
And if they're not real well,
then I can trample over them all I want
because they're not real.
But if they,
and then we can just have an argument
about what human beings are like,
but if they are real and they're
reflective,
an underlying principle that's
continually attempting to manifest
itself in a sense from the bottom up,
you better not break the rules because
you're really going against the cosmic
order.
So that's the Egyptian story.
It's like,
oh,
it's mind boggling.
It's no wonder that story had enough
dynamism to,
to propel a whole culture across several
thousand years.
It's like it's a staggering achievement.
Ready today is sort of a primary,
yeah,
don't.
So that's a really good,
that's a really good observation.
That's just one of the things that I
really,
it's something new that I've figured out
about all of this in the last five
years.
For a long time,
I still haven't got this right.
It's like,
okay,
what is your reaction when one of those
principles is violated?
So this is like the terror management
question,
right?
Well,
for the terror management people,
it's fear,
but there's a real problem with that
because conservatives tend to be less
neurotic than liberals and conservatives
who have more of a propensity for right
wing authoritarianism are more likely to
get upset when rules are violated.
But the rules seem to be,
so,
I think it's more,
or I thought that it was more,
no,
it's not exactly.
If your rules get violated,
it's not exactly fear,
although fears part of it,
it's the disintegration of your
motivational states into general
preparation for,
for readiness.
So that's more like a generalized stress
response and so everything goes on so
that you're able to deal with what
happens next.
It's like Gottman's married couples when
they're the ones that are going to get
divorced,
right?
They're very calm on the surface.
But underneath it's like the underworld,
all hell is broke loose,
but then there's been a twist in that
because there's a bunch of data coming
together from all over the world that
basically goes like this is that right
wing authoritarianism seems to be based
on purity and purity is discussed
control and there's a deep biological
route route for that.
Like people who are disgust sensitive
and concerned with purity have better
standards of hygiene and they do tend to
live longer,
but they're also very much against
temperamentally against any form of
sexual contact.
It isn't bounded by the social contract
and they don't like foreigners,
but that's all a clump.
It's all the same thing.
And then we've found recently,
we haven't published this yet,
we've found recently that we know
conservatives are more conscientious
than liberals.
And then we found that conscientiousness
fragments into industriousness and
orderliness,
which was great because people have been
wondering for five decades how you plug
the proclivity for right wing
authoritarianism into the general
personality structure.
And it's complicated because if you're a
radical liberal like a lefty,
those aren't liberals.
Sorry,
radical lefty,
a communist.
You can be just,
it seems like you can be just as
authoritarian as you would be if you
were a fascist.
So you know,
that hasn't been quite sorted out yet,
but it's the orderliness that seems to
make people have this right wing
proclivity and it does look like what
they're trying to do is control
discussed.
So yes.
So what,
what the violation of that order,
a huge chunk of it seems to be in this
entirely new negative emotion system
that we've only been untangling for 20
years and it's not associated with
neuroticism.
Liberals are actually more neurotic than
conservatives.
You know,
when you could say,
well that's because the conservatives
are so well protected.
It's like,
no,
you,
you can't post hoc use your theory to
predict the opposite of what you would
have predicted before the data comes in.
And it's like,
no,
conservatives are,
they should be more physiologically
reactive and there's some evidence that
they are,
but it does really seem to be discussed.
And so to jump ahead a little bit,
when and after we'd sorted this out,
now a lot of the work that was done on
disgust was done by Jonathan Haidt.
He's the guy that deserves the credit
for the discussed purity linkage.
It's a big deal.
And he was pushing a study of discussed
long before people were paying any
attention to it.
So good for him.
When I was working on the orderliness
discussed relationship,
I was also reading this book by Hitler
called Hitler's table talk.
And what it was was,
uh,
he would talk at his dinners and they
collected it from 1939 to 1942 and he
would like just spout off on whatever it
was that was on his mind.
And he was a very open person.
So it's very lateral discussion.
He was very interested in art and
culture,
but he was very,
very orderly and he was a worshiper of
willpower and orderly.
People are like that like,
um,
anorexics are orderly to orderly.
They can't even stand their own bodies.
It's discussed that their bodies elicit
and they prize the ability to control
their bodies.
And that's hyper orderliness.
That's I think why it's associated.
It's generally considered an upper
middle class disease.
And I think that's because a lot of
people who are at that strata are hyper
conscientious and that gets passed onto
their kids and sometimes that's just too
much.
Anyways,
one of the things that really struck me
about Hitler's writings,
and it really,
it really blew me away,
I'll tell you,
was that he has a metaphor.
All of this thinking's metaphorical,
and the metaphor is the area in race is
a pure body,
pure blood,
pure uncontaminated,
and it's under assault by pathogens and
parasites.
Now,
as soon as you know that bang he's got
is you've got the underlying dynamic of,
of his appeal to the masses and Germans,
hey,
they're orderly.
So you know,
one of the things people say is that
what happened in Germany constituted
that decline of civilization,
right back to barbarism.
It's like,
ah,
maybe not.
Conscientiousness is associated with
productivity,
quite highly correlations about 0.4,
roughly the same as the correlation with
Iq.
So conscientiousness is a prerequisite
for civilization.
And you can think,
well,
why would you be disgust sensitive and
an orderly?
And the answer might be,
well,
how much of your grain do you want rats
and mice to eat because they eat lots of
it,
right?
And keeping the insects out of food
store,
that's really,
really hard.
So if you're going to store things up,
which is what you're going to do,
if you're going to be civilized,
you better start to be concerned with
hygiene,
you know?
So those things are gonna go together.
Well,
Hitler was hyper orderly and hyper
disgust sensitive.
He'd washes,
he bathed four times a day and he was
very,
very happy about the ability to stand in
the back of his car,
has prayed car and keep his arm out like
this for eight hours.
He thought of that is the triumph of the
will.
You know when the will seem to be
associated with this pro propensity
towards orderliness.
So another thing that's really
interesting and,
and I still don't exactly know what to
make of this because it has complicated
my conceptualization because a lot of
what I'm going to show you is based on
fear and horror and horror is more like
fear plus discussed.
It's some,
you know the difference between the
Blair witch project and the Texas
chainsaw massacre.
They're both horror movies,
but one is pure fear and the other is
almost pure discussed.
So disgust seems to be a huge element of
this and it is a primary response by
orderly people to the violation of moral
norms.
Now here's something weird.
There was a paper published in Plos one
about a year ago and what these people
did was they,
they did I think I within and across
country survey,
and this wasn't in developed countries.
So the question was how much infectious
disease was there in each of these
geographical locales?
And the next question was how right wing
were the people who occupied those areas
at the individual level?
So they weren't interested in what the
government was like.
And what they found was that the
correlation between the prevalence of
infectious diseases and right wing
authoritarianism at the individual level
was 0.6
it's like,
and if you know anything about
statistics,
when you see 0.6
you just fall over at hyperventilate
because that never happens.
It's an effect size that's,
it's bigger than 99% of the effect sizes
that you never encounter in the social
sciences.
It might be 99.9%
higher.
The infectious disease rate,
the more right wing totalitarian the
population.
Why?
Well,
why do you think they're regulating
inter personal contact and sexual
behavior?
Why?
Well,
think about it.
You know,
they're trying to minimize disease
transmission vectors fundamentally.
Now they're not trying to do that.
You know what I mean?
It's an ad that patient,
keep yourself out of contact,
keep yourself isolated
cause it takes place within a
generation.
Well,
I don't know.
I don't know that you know,
because lots of those places,
there've been infectious diseases for a
very long period of time.
So,
but anyway,
so that's all very unsettling
information because it sheds it.
So what did it implies?
And this is quite cool,
it implies that the best way to control
right wing authoritarianism is to,
is to instigate effective public health
policy.
So if you all,
if everyone has a sewer and a toilet and
there's no infectious disease,
there aren't any right wing
authoritarians anymore cause they're not
necessary.
Now that might be an overstatement,
but,
but it also might not be,
you know,
it's definitely one of the prerequisites
for the kind of stability and
productivity that's characterized the
west is that all of our cities has have
functional sewer systems and everybody
has a toilet.
It's like,
it turns out that makes a big
difference,
especially when you don't have one.
Is it fair to say?
Well it should,
it should bring it out.
You know,
and I'm,
I'm a reasonably orderly person.
You know,
if I go into a place that's chaotic,
especially if it's chaotic and,
and,
and filthy,
I have a really,
really powerful impulse to tromp around
until it's fixed.
You know?
Cause it just strikes me as things are
deteriorating in a bad direction around
here.
You know,
so,
and I'm not,
I wouldn't say that.
What am I most outstanding
characteristics as orderliness,
but it's,
it's,
it's up there.
I'm a reasonably conscientious person.
So yeah,
it's a visceral response and the
visceral responses,
something needs to be done about this,
you know,
and you can see how that's associated
with conscientiousness.
So what we've been trying to figure out,
what makes conscientious people
motivated because conscientiousness
predicts life success.
It's like,
well,
are they interested in what they're
doing?
No,
it's due to fullness.
Okay.
So why is that a motivator?
We're thinking that what the
conscientious person wants is not to
slide into the disgusting bottom of
things.
So imagine the hierarchy.
Okay.
Top is pure bottom is contaminated.
Why?
Well,
I can tell you one reason.
If you take a given geographical locale,
this is even true for songbirds.
And you'll rank order the denisons of
that locale by their dominance position.
And then you let a pathogen in the
animals die from the bottom up,
right?
So the bottom of the dominance hierarchy
is where all the pathogens hang out.
And if that's disgusting and it's
morally impure and you're bad if you're
down there,
which is really a conservative
viewpoint,
many ways it's your fault you're there,
right,
and are not going to be there no matter
what.
And so I think what the conscientious
person is doing is fleeting the bottom.
They're not trying to get to the top
except that that's the farthest away you
can get from the bottom.
And that's a purity motivation.
Now we don't know that yet because we
haven't been able to figure out how to
motivate industrious people in the
lounge.
So which is weird,
right?
Because conscientiousness predicts life
success.
You'd think that you could find a task
in the lab that conscientious people
would do better than non conscientious
people.
We've tried dozens of things and not
being able to do it.
So now we're,
we're trying to make people embarrassed
and ashamed and see if we could get them
to like donate more to a charity if we
do that.
Based on the idea that what's motivating
the conscientious person is a flight
from contamination could easily be.
So it's quite mind boggling.
Like it was a twist.
It was a twist.
I,
I'd never,
I'd never forecast in my
conceptualization of these things.
But the underworld,
you know,
it's a place of chaos and fear,
but the underworld that's hell,
it's full of sulfur is odors,
you know,
it's,
it's not only terrifying,
it's also disgusting and it's associated
symbolically with disgusting elements of
the body as well.
So,
and purity,
obviously sexual purity for example,
is certainly a hygiene purity add
mixture and it's,
it's,
it's flight from contamination and no
wonder,
right.
I mean there are sexually transmitted
diseases.
It's like a major vector of disease
transmission.
We saw that with the AIDS outbreak.
You know,
without,
without us airplanes,
there wouldn't have been any aids
outbreak,
you know,
jet planes plus promiscuity.
It was like,
Hey,
you know,
we almost generated a virus that took
down the whole planet.
So it's no joke when these things escape
from their,
from their little box,
you know,
you might say,
well,
why aren't people allowed to have the
sexual life they want?
Well,
the disease there,
the relationship between disease
transmission and promiscuity is
exponential.
That's why.
So you know,
you might think,
well that's no reason.
It's like,
okay,
maybe not,
but
I dunno how many hundreds of millions of
people have died from aids,
but it's lots
so you know.
Yup,
we'll do that later.
We're going to be doing a lot of
distinguishing of that.
In fact,
that's a primary problem of men
distinguishing Isis.
So that's the feminine underworld from
evil.
Right?
Right.
Because the,
because because there there's a negative
element to both of them.
If you haven't differentiated properly,
then the woman can carry that whole
load.
That happened to some degree with eve
for example,
in the,
in the genesis story,
it's so interesting because if you read
genesis,
we're going to talk about that later.
The person who looks really bad in
genesis isn't eve.
The person who looks really bad is Adam.
No.
So either offers him the apple and like
a dance.
He takes it but then God comes along
afterwards.
He's all self conscious now and so is
eve.
And so God comes along to have a little
walk without him like he's used to
doing.
And Adam is hiding in the bushes because
he's naked and he doesn't want God to
see.
And so God calls them on,
it says like,
hey buddy,
I can see through bushes,
you know,
come out here where I can talk to you.
And Adam says,
oh,
a naked,
I can't come out.
And God says,
how do you figure that out?
And Adam being there,
heroic creature that he was said,
you know that woman you made for me,
it's her fault.
It's like,
well,
who's the villain in that story?
He such a weasel that when he gets
called on his disobedience,
the first thing he does is blame the
woman.
It's like,
yeah,
well that's an archetypal story.
I'll tell you that.
You know,
soul,
the temptations of Eve,
you know,
it's like the rapist to blame the
attractiveness of the woman for the
rape.
It's like the devil made me do it,
you know?
So anyways,
it's very difficult to distinguish one
form of negative from another.
And partly what we're going to do when
we go through the symbolic
differentiation process is put things in
their proper place.
So I would say that's this,
nope,
that's the wrong direction.
Sorry,
I want to show you this one diagram and
then we'll stop.
Okay.
There.
So for me,
that's the map of the symbolic sphere.
Okay.
So what you have in the very background
is the dragon of chaos.
That's the absolute unknown as such.
So you can think about it is the chaos
from which everything else emerges.
So that's the unknown unknowns.
Okay?
On top of that,
there's a feminine layer and that's the
great mother.
And the great mother has a positive
aspect.
She's mother of all things and she has a
negative aspect and she's,
she's angry.
Tie Amat the force of death that pulls
all biological creatures back into her
grasp,
creation and destruction.
So on top of that,
there's culture and culture protects you
from the great mother.
Just like with OCI receipt.
Isis stays in the underworld where she
belongs.
But culture has a negative element in a
positive element.
So it's,
it's patriarchal represented by
masculine sagers.
But it has an element that offers order
and an element that offers tyranny.
And there's always a balance between
those two.
And so if you're a conservative,
you think hooray order.
And if you're a lefty,
you think,
oh no tyranny.
And you're both right,
right?
Because every organization tends towards
tyranny and supports you at the same
time.
So it's,
it's right on top of that.
There's the archetipal individual that's
also represented in masculine form for
reasons that we'll get into later,
but it has a positive and a negative
two.
And the positive is the creative
explorer moving out into the darkness
with Eyes Open.
And then there's the counterpart of
that,
which is the thing you shake hands with
when you're Romeo Dallaire and you shake
hands with the devil.
And that's the individual too.
And one of the things I would,
you can think about this,
but one of the things that I really like
about this map is that I think it's the
antidote for radiology.
And the reason for that is that you can
map it theologies onto this map,
but the ideology is only give you half
the story.
So like the last wing story would be
lovely,
virginal mother nature being tyrannized
by the evil corporations as civilization
advances led by the adversarial
individual.
But the right wing story is the heroic
individual bringing order into chaos to
avoid the destructive element of,
of the natural world.
So That's like the frontier myth that,
that,
that uh,
that settled the United States,
right?
Heroic pioneers moving civilization into
the chaotic unknown and just slam those
two together.
And then you've got the real problem,
which is that nature slash the unknown
is a creative source of everything.
And it will pull you into pieces if,
if it has the opportunity.
And then culture,
it's like you can talk and it's warm.
You better be happy with culture,
but the probability that it's going to
take you and crunch you and try to turn
you into a car,
he's like,
yeah,
that's what it's going to do.
That's what it does.
And then there's you,
well,
yeah,
you're wonderful,
interesting.
You know,
great creature,
but look the hell out.
So,
and that's right.
That,
and I think the archetipal stories do a
lovely job of continually bringing those
elements together,
so well.
Okay.
So that's good enough.